hey guys it is the 27th of October today
my name is Jasper tunnel and you're
tuned into gamespot news first up call
of duty advanced warfare has leaked a
week before its official release and
predictably developer sledgehammer games
is pretty bummed about it co-founder
Glenn Schofield address the leak on
Twitter saying we took three years to
make a game kept it quiet for the fairs
and it's been stolen and leaked a week
before that sucks a real bummer thanks a
lot an early copy of the game was
broadcast on Twitch by user and Rooney
29 and although the stream and channel
was shut down gamers still discovered a
bunch of spoilers for new gameplay
features spoilers that you can find on
gamespot if you're so inclined the
report has indicated that GTA 5 is going
to run at 1080p on ps4 there's no
official confirmation of the resolution
but UK publication official PlayStation
Magazine has written glimmering 1080p
presentation hugely increased draw a
distance 100 new songs fresh wildlife a
bumper version of GTA online this is the
sandbox you've dreamt about ever since
he slaughtered Sony's angular baby under
your TV the article goes on to reference
that the game does indeed run at a
native 1920 x 1080 resolution GTA 5 ps4
is set to land on november 18 while the
pc version is coming on january 27
finally the Xbox one is set to receive a
major price cut just in time for the
holidays that so long as you live in the
US sorry November to the console is
getting a fifty dollar price cut and the
limited time reduction applies to any
Xbox one console the Kinect free xbox
one will now run you 350 bucks and with
a kinect on top it's 450 but the Xbox
one game bundles have also been affected
this means the Assassin's Creed bundle
without connect also comes up to 350
while with Kinect is four hundred and
fifty dollars additionally you can grab
the xbox one sunset overdrive bundle for
350 bucks
motion is valid until january three next
year so give it a think if you've been
mulling over a new gen console purchase
as for your question of the day let me
know if fifty dollars off is enough to
encourage you to buy an xbox one and why
or why not if you're after more stories
we've got bits and pieces on yet another
star citizen milestone and why sunset
overdrive isn't making it over to pc on
gamespot that is it for me today thanks
for stopping by as always and I will
catch the same time tomorrow